and he is extremely out I could have
talked for hours about almost any but
unlike most of our guests he come to me
with a very specific request
I never expected yeah his mother
Marjorie Sandberg was adopted at birth I
feel and she spent her whole life and
wondering about her biological parents
listed she's trying to find the multiple
times she even hired a private
investigator and he is hoping that will
succeed where so many others had failed
it's something that I really wished for
my mother because I know that it would
be something to to give her peace about
it just to know how important is it to
you well my mother is basically the
kindest person I've ever known and many
people would corroborate that uh-huh
and when I was asked about doing this
the first call I made was to my mom and
I said I know that you've always been
curious there's a chance they could
figure this out I don't usually do stuff
like this because I generally don't like
putting too much personal stuff out
there right and so I would absolutely
not even consider it a little bit unless
it's something you want to do and what'd
she say she said let me think about it
and then she called me back pretty
quickly after and said I think we should
go for it till you think it's important
to you both I know it is she's she's
very very hopeful to find out mm-hmm
she's been wanting to know for you know
60 plus years
[Music]
[Applause]